[Music]
amanda is in canada hi amanda how are
you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i was just calling um my husband and i
are technically on baby step
three but i will confess i have been
cheating your system we still have our
credit card and we do not do a monthly
budget
um i've been on step three since march
2020 because we've had to buy two cars
which we paid for with cash
and um we had a baby so we had all the
expenses of that too
oh and there was this little covet thing
that happened yeah okay not a bad not a
bad year
no it was quite the year um but
i am now at the point where we get to
the end of each month and i have no idea
where all of our money went and i'm just
sick and tired of it because we want to
be saving to
have our emergency fund and do a down
payment on a house because we're
currently renting
good um but the thought of budgeting
really freaks me out my husband is in
construction so his
income isn't necessarily always for sure
each month
and so on what freaks you out
it just all be different uh
what if that could come up in a month or
like if my husband
worked overtime we get more money or if
you stick a day we lose money and then
how do you
put that in a budget when you you don't
know what's going to happen
okay so you need a process and a system
to
handle the ups and downs in the
irregular part of your world
the unpredictable part of your world in
order to not be freaked out right
is that what you're telling me yeah yeah
is there something else freaking you out
about the budget
i just i i love planning everything i
like knowing everything in advance
and um and you're not going to be able
to
yes okay so here's how you do it okay
what portion of his income
like out of the last uh how long has he
been doing construction
he's in year four of his apprenticeship
okay let's just say
three year for the last three years what
was his worst
month of income
uh just pick a rough number
two grand two grand what's his best
uh about five grand okay so that's a
range of irregular income
and are you working outside the home as
well
uh i'm currently on maternity leave
until
next may
okay and with that i get about thirteen
hundred dollars a month
okay so we have thirteen hundred and two
thousand that we count on right
right okay and so you do a budget on
3300
okay and uh if you want to do a little
bit more because you probably could
count on a little more than 2 000 out of
him right yeah
so you you pick the number you can count
on that's what my point is
and you run a budget on that meaning you
put that at the top of the page
on your every dollar budget and you give
every dollar a name
and then you make a list of things you
want to do or need to do that didn't
make the cut
and you prioritize that list if i get a
dollar more than 3 300 what am i gonna
do
i'm gonna put it on number one once
number one's done i'm gonna put it on
number two
number three number four number five
number six number seven so you have a
prioritized spending plan on
items that didn't make the 3 300
budget and now you have a system